during the process of assigning the
network addresses for each of the device
in a network system the use of ip
addresses becomes too massive and leads
to the wastage of network addresses
in today's topic we will learn about a
network concept that plays an important
role in overcoming such a situation
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn but
before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
now without further ado let's take a
look at the agenda for today's topic
in the beginning we will learn about
what is submitting
then continue with what are class
addresses and subnet mask
characteristics of submitting
then see some of the benefits of using
submitting process
and lastly the drawbacks of using
submitting
let's begin
the first heading is what is subnetting
the process of subnetting is to divide
the network into smaller network paths
this allows the system to have better
connectivity in the system it also
increases the security measures for the
network against hacking attempts and
also maintains an efficient flow of
network traffic
the smaller divided units of the network
are known as sub networks
taking an example of an ip address
with slash 24 representing the subnet
mask can be divided into two sub
networks of slash 25 subnet mask
which can further be divided into
smaller sub networks
now that we understand what is
subnetting let's move on to class
addresses and subnet mask
firstly let's begin with class addresses
to better understand the submitting
process we need some information
regarding different classes used in ip
address
where the first class is class a
with the range of 0 to 127
network bits as slash 8
then we have class p with the range of
128 to 191
with network bits as 16
and lastly we have class c
with network range of 192 to 223
with network bits as 24.
the network bits representing each class
are very important when making subnets
of a particular ip address
let's see how they do so
for this we'll be representing each
class in binary format for class a we
have 1
for 8 bits
for class b 16 bits and class c 24 bits
moving on we will see what exactly is
the subnet mask
to better define the sub networks in the
system we require the use of a subnet
mask
that is the subnet mask is a way to
differentiate between the portion of an
ip address that represents the network
address id and the host network id
in this
let's see the default subnet mask for
each of the class
for class a we have 255.0.0.0
for class b we have 255.255.0.0
whereas for class c we have 255.25
to better understand this let's take a
look at the classes individually
the network id part is the one that
represents the binary digit 1 whereas
host id represents binary digit 0.
that means for class a we have 8-bit
cells network id and the remaining bits
as host id
by looking at the host id we can see
that the network addresses that are
available for the host is the largest in
the class a
whereas for class b we have 16 bits for
network id and the remaining for host id
where we can see the remaining part for
the host id is lesser than class a that
means
class b can assign network ids for a
medium level company
and lastly for class c we have 24 bits
as network id and the remaining for host
id from this we can see that the host id
used for class c is the lowest that
means only smaller division companies
can use class c
moving on let's take a look at the
characteristics of the subnetting
process
first is the network id which represent
the first ip address in each subnet
block then we have broadcast id which
indicates the last ip address of the sub
network block
moving on we have first host id which is
the immediate first ip address after the
network id
then we have
last host id as the name suggests it
defines the ip address before the
broadcast id
continuing we have
next network id
this defines the network id of the next
subnet block
then we have the total number of ip
addresses
in the sub network block and lastly we
have subnet mask or
which represents the network id and the
host id part in an ip address
to better understand all the attributes
of the subnetting
let's take a look at an example
in this example we are assuming an ip
address 192.168.0
point x with a subnet mask of 24.
for this ip address we have divided it
into four parts that represent slash 25
slash 27 slash 27 and last part as slash
26
now let's find out the details that
means the attributes for the sub network
slash 25.
the first attribute is
the number of ip addresses
going by the table
we have 0 to 256 addresses in a single
block
but in this slash 25 represent only 0 to
128
that means the total number of addresses
in slash 25 subnet block is
128.
moving on we'll find out subnet mask or
citer
that is the default subnet mask of class
c
which i have taken reference from the
subnet table which was explained in the
earlier slide
which is 255.255.
then we have the network id
which represents the topmost network
address in the sub network block in our
case it is 192.168.0.0
then we have broadcast id which is the
last ip address in any sub network block
in our case it is 192.168.0.1
moving on the network id and the
broadcast id addresses cannot be
assigned to any network device in the
network
because the network id is used to
identify the sub network block in a
network
along with broadcast id which is used to
communicate with any of the host that is
connected to the sub network block
that also means that the total number of
usable
network id addresses in a network block
is total number of ip addresses minus 2
that represents network id and broadcast
id
that would be
128 minus 2 and we get the value 126
which represents the total number of ip
addresses that are usable
moving on
the next attribute is first host id
that means
the first id after the network id which
is 192.168.0.1
then we have the last host id
which is 192.168
which is just before the broadcast id
and lastly the next network id
which is 192.168.0
point
now that we are clear about all the
characteristics of our sub network how
about a practice round for everyone to
find all the characteristics for the sub
network block slash 27 subnet mask
you can give your answers in the comment
section
let's move on to the benefits of using
subnetting
where the first benefit is enhanced
network efficiency
through the use of applications of
subnetting we can share data to not only
a specific portion of the network model
rather than broadcasting to the whole
network causing unnecessary traffic in
the channel as shown in the example
over here we see four different host and
if we want to share a specific data put
only two of the host we can subnet them
into specific parts
through this the router will only send
data to the specific portion of a sub
network rather than broadcasting to the
whole network channel this will prevent
network traffic
moving on the other benefit of using
subnetting process is
network security
separating also provides protection to
an extent against any hacking attempts
made on the network model
due to the complexity of the sub
networks as presented in the example
during the hacking attempt if we can
identify how the virus attacks the
network model we can prevent it from
attacking all the sub networks by
compromising a single or two of them and
preventing the remaining sub networks
let's move on to the drawbacks of using
subnetting process
the very first drawback of using the
subnetting process is it makes the
network model much more complex
which in turns affects the maintenance
and efficiency
then we have the unused ip addresses
which are left over
from applying the network model in a sub
network process
and lastly we have the low efficiency
use of hardware devices
if the hardware devices such as router
or switch is used are of low efficiency
the performance of the sub network is
also decreased
with this we have reached the end of the
session if you have any questions
regarding the topic you can ask them in
the comment section thank you for
watching